I saw this movie alone with the general
population and somehow I thought I would
not feel like a creep but I did Vampire
Academy so Vampire Academy is the newest
addition to the craze of teen vampire
fiction it starts a couple of really
attractive chicks as the main stars in
this movie one's a vampire she's gonna
be queen she's all royal and the
other ones are a human guardian and
together in the Vampire Academy they
have to take on such dark forces like
gossip yeah among other things but okay
here we go I saw the trailer for this
movie and I thought alright it has some
kind of snappy witty dialogue going on
in the trailer maybe this will be a
little more fun maybe this won't be more
of the same old and there is a
part of me that wants to give credit to
this movie for trying
it does have snappy dialogue but in the
end it doesn't help the movie at all it
makes you want to like it more than you
actually do in the end I was still
sitting there gone I'm so interested
when I say uninteresting I really do
mean uninteresting the characters they
didn't interest me I didn't give a
about the lore in this movie the least a
movie like this can do is make me care
about the lore vampire movies are based
around rules and lore and this movie had
it but Elva alright next all the while I
was just checking my watch going I don't
care that's the worst thing a movie like
this does you just don't care about the
stakes if they had really good stay I
mean I don't mean stakes is a double
meaning here I mean stakes doesn't if
they had higher stakes I'd be like okay
cool the stakes are high maybe the
world's ending or something but you
don't feel like that you don't care
about the characters you don't care
about what's happening you don't care
about the rules you don't care about
who's breaking the rules you don't care
about who's trying to save who from what
it's like a mystery movie that's just a
bad mystery movie you can see that
Vampire Academy was made so people try
to care they were like alright we're
gonna do something different if they're
actually gonna say and damn it
they're gonna curse they're gonna talk a
little more real they're gonna talk
really fast because people like that
this movie did a better job than a lot
of young adult book to movie adaptations
have done lately but in the end it's not
the best that's happened it's not good
enough in the end Vampire Academy was a
good try but you're not gonna remember
it in t-minus a day vampire movie still
sucked alright that was a double meaning
I didn't
care about a single sentient being in
this movie none of them I cared about
nothing but you see your favorite
vampire story of all time what is it
mine legacy of kain I don't know if you
know the legacy of Kane but I know
legacy of Cain and I love that
whatever it is comment below let me know
and as always if you like what you've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]